good morning John wrote this song after
we went on tour because people kept
asking me a question and I didn't have
an answer to and this song is my answer
to that question there's something
happening on the internet and I don't
really get it
once again I'll have to say I'm not into
that but I'm sure that I'll regret it
cuz I know thousands of people never
cared about anything more they've spent
the last six months making tumblers
fanfic and bulletin boards and I think
all that excitement is great but when
they ask I have no choice and I still
have to see that I don't have a favorite
phony because I've never seen that show
and I don't have a favorite pony cuz I'm
31 years old and I don't have a favorite
pony cuz I'm a self-respecting dude and
I don't have a favorite pony cuz I
light just can't - well - the Pegasus
has rained O'Hare in the Cubist duty
mark and Applejack is the strongest
mayor always working so hard and
Fluttershy has totally got that Maryland
vibe going on but when it comes to the
beauty prize Oh rarity is already won
and Pinkie Pie's excitement could view a
jet plane but Twilight's the nerdiest
and that goes a long way but I don't
have a favorite pony because I've never
seen that show and I don't have a
favorite pony because I'm 31 years old
and I don't have a favorite pony cause I
just can't chew well high goal is to
make this a better planet I don't take
that Michael - where you working my butt
off all day damn it with any luck that
might be but it's equally probable that
instead of changing the world I spent
the last six hours watching a cartoon
made for a little girl so battles in the
real world are so complexly one it falls
topless in Equestria I don't have a
favorite pony I don't know that even
though I'm spittle they'd rather pick by
watching all episodes I don't have a
favorite toy because of a
self-respecting guy and I don't have a
favorite Pony kazar
I like spike thank you michael aranda of
course for doing the effects and also to
the people who put together a bunch of
green screen ponies ponies links to
their channel well done i'm at leakycon
right now i've boomed this in the past
but i'm not gonna talk about it cuz you
know if you're watching this you're
either there you're not what I am gonna
talk about cuz John maybe you aren't as
excited about this as I am is the evil
baby orphanage card game Kickstarter I'm
a tabletop card game kind of guy and I
have shamed of that my original
nerdfighter song was about Magic the
Gathering if you remember I probably
don't it was a long time ago and you may
not thus remember the evil baby
orphanage but if you don't it was an
idea that John and I conceived in order
to escape the conundrum of whether or
not to kill baby Hitler if you had the
chance cuz if you had the chance to kill
him you also have the chance to abduct
him and bring him to an evil baby
orphanage all the very talented people
at weird games got their hands on this
idea and when I saw it on Kickstarter I
was like hey guys guys guys guys can I
can I help can I help guys can I help so
they gave me a look at the whole game
it's basically like you have to collect
babies to get mischief points and you
get more mission points and eventually
you win there are a bunch of Mechanics
for babies that have more mischief
points get like passed from time nanny
to die many also you're a time nanny and
a fifty thousand dollars they're gonna
do a nerdfighter expansion which will
include John and me as time nannies you
will be able to play as us but you only
get that and the other expansion perks
coloring book stuff if you pledge more
than forty dollars so remember that and
if you're seeing this video after the
Kickstarter ends it's ending very soon
in like two or three days don't fret the
game will be available for sale at your
local game stores and probably at
dftba.com John I will see you right now
cuz you're at League on to buy I don't
have a favorite pony because I've never
seen that show and I don't have a
favorite pony because I'm 31 years old
Sony's no self-respecting dude in I
don't have a favorite pony
I just can't you